me personally I've never claimed to own  property myself I have never claimed to  own property myself okay that's pretty  clear no I do not own property I've I've  never purchased property under my name  ever got your family property I think  your company has property and I'm able  to use of their property and I help them  out with uh you know keeping the books  and stuff like that but that's a family  affair okay so no property doesn't have  property never claim to own property  here he is saying he sold the property  uh okay let's see if I've got this lined  up right let's take a listen  i i two years ago I sold a property I  had on 28th Avenue I sold a property I  had not I helped my family sell a  property of theirs I sold a property I  had